it happens all the time I was Mexican
and I'm not Mexican anymore I'm
mexican-american and I was Mexican and
I'm I'm an immigrant and I realize now
that I spend more years living here in
the united states that in that in Mexico
and I think we just have to admit that
you can be from two countries and at
some point you don't have to decide in
other words you don't have to choose in
between Mexico or el salvador Colombia
or Venezuela and the United States you
can be actually from from two countries
and that's perfectly fine I have two
passports from Mexico and from the
United States I can vote in Mexico and
the United States and and I'm fine with
that double identity sometimes might be
confusing to some people but it is not
confusing to me anymore once I remember
talking about this with isabella ii and
the famous chillin writer and she told
me that after nine eleven she realized
that she was both from chilean from the
united states and that she didn't have
to choose and many of us decide to
become american and that is there
anything more powerful and beautiful
than choosing your own country and that
that country chooses you at the same
time I that experience it's something
that you can find I'm sure in most of
them in most of the world it's something
uniquely American
in the last election 2012 about 12
million Latinos went to the polls in
2016 about 16 million Latinos will go to
the polls and there's a new rule in
American politics and it's beautiful it
is that no one can make it to the White
House without the Hispanic vote and this
is knew it wasn't true in the past in
the past still Bob Dole the Republican
candidate in 1996 decided not to talk to
the Hispanic media into the
spanish-language media because he didn't
think it was important he lost and after
that every single Republican and
Democratic candidate have decided to
talk to the Hispanic media into Spanish
language media because they know the
importance of the Hispanic vote in very
in a very close election and the next
election is going to be very close again
Latinos will decide 16 million votes
will decide who's going to be the next
president of the United States and it
started in the year 2000 when just about
500 cuban-american vote decided that
george w bush with the help of the
supreme court was going to be present of
of this country and then george w bush
got forty four percent of the hispanic
vote in 2004 and Barack Obama in 2008
got sixty-seven percent and then 71
percent in the year 2012 so it is
incredibly important and what we are
realizing is that for the first time we
could get something in return for our
vote and the Latino board will never be
the same in the past they could ignore
us now they have to take into
consideration that we are important part
of this country
at this point unfortunately what I'm
seeing is much more polarization I am
discouraged and frustrated when I see
that there is no possibility of of real
politics of compromise in Washington and
that Democrats and Republicans are
fighting for for what seems to be a
different country so what I'm when I'm
seeing in the future in the next few
months in the next 19 months during the
campaign is much more polarization and
at the end this country is going through
an incredible demographic revolution
this country is becoming much more
diverse multi-ethnic multiracial and
that means that no one is going to be
the majority and when you have a country
without a majority democracy has to work
and at this point the system isn't
working at some point we're going to
have to to find a way of negotiating and
realizing that despite our differences
the only way to do something is putting
together Democrats and Republicans and
that at this point are not seen
you